I just absolutely love Hassan calling
Ian Crossland a conservative that just
right there shows you that it is a thin
veneer of grifting bro any reasonable
person leftists for instance they call
Ian Moon Lord because they know he's a
hippie dippy Crystal Weirdo And he Rags
on Trump all the time who in their right
mind would call this guy conservative
unless you're a grifter just saying
whatever you think you need to say to
earn internet points or your tribe and
you're a cult because if you're in a
cult if anybody Strays from the cult or
tribal narrative they're gone yeah but
it only takes one even among woke
leftists they call Ian moonlord
right they like these socialists who are
very woke are like yeah Ian's not a
conservative he's a weirdo he's a hippie
weird they call him Moon Lord they laugh
about it and they like sometimes when he
when he yells at Trump and stuff Hassan
is just
I'm gonna say whatever you know if
you're a onb I'm just gonna say whatever
I think people are gonna you know click
on